I consider myself one part artist and
one part designer and I work at an
artificial intelligence research lab
we're trying to create technology that
you'll want to interact with in the far
future not just six months from now but
try years and decades from now and we're
taking a moonshot that we'll want to be
interacting with computers in deeply
emotional ways so in order to do that
the technology has to be just as much
human as it is artificial it has to get
you you know like that inside joke
that'll have you and your best friend on
the floor cracking up or that look of
disappointment that you can just smell
from miles away
I view art as the Gateway to help us
bridge this gap between human and
machine to figure out what it means to
get each other so that we can train AI
to get us see to me art is a way to put
tangible experiences to intangible ideas
feelings and emotions and I think it's
one of the most human things about us
see we're a complicated and complex
Bunch we have what feels like an
infinite range of emotions and to top it
off we're all different we have
different family backgrounds different
experiences and different psychologies
and this is what makes life really
interesting but this is also what makes
working on intelligent technology
extremely difficult and right now AI
research well it's a bit lopsided on the
tech side and that makes a lot of sense
see for every qualitative thing about us
you know those parts of us that are
emotional dynamic and subjective we have
to convert it to a quantitative metric
something that can be represented with
facts figures and computer code the
issue is there are many qualitative
things that we just can't put our finger
on
think about hearing your favorite song
for the first time what were you doing
how did you feel
did you get goosebumps or did you get
fired up hard to describe right see
parts of us feel so simple but under the
surface there's really a ton of
complexity and translating that
complexity to machines is what makes
them modern-day moon shots and I'm not
convinced that we can answer these
deeper questions with just ones and
zeros alone so in the lab I've been
creating art as a way to help me design
better experiences for bleeding edge
technology and it's been serving as a
catalyst to beef up the more human ways
that computers can relate to us through
art we're tackling some of the hardest
questions like what does it really mean
to feel or how do we engage and know how
to be present with each other and how
does intuition affect the way that we
interact so take for example human
emotion right now computers can make
sense of our most basic ones like joy
sadness anger fear and disgust by
converting those characteristics to math
but what about the more complex emotions
you know those emotions that we have a
hard time describing to each other like
nostalgia so to explore this I created a
piece of art and experience that asked
people to share a memory and I teamed up
with some data scientists to figure out
how to take an emotion that's so highly
subjective and convert it into something
mathematically precise so we created
what we call a nostalgia score and it's
the heart of this installation to do
that the installation asks you to share
a story the computer then analyzes it
for it's simpler emotions it checks for
your tendency to use past tense wording
and also looks for words that we tend to
associate with nostalgia like home
childhood and the past it then creates a
nostalgia score to indicate how
nostalgic your story is and that score
is the driving force behind these
light-based sculptures that's
servus physical embodiments of your
contribution and the higher the score
the rosier the hue you know like looking
at the world through rose-colored
glasses so when you see your score and
the physical and representation of it
sometimes you'd agree and sometimes you
wouldn't it's as if it really understood
how that experience made you feel but
other times it gets tripped up and how's
he thinking it doesn't understand you at
all but the piece really serves to show
that if we have a hard time explaining
the emotions that we have to each other
how can we teach a computer to make
sense of them so even the more objective
parts about being human are hard to
describe
like conversation have you ever really
tried to break down the steps
so think about sitting with your friend
at a coffee shop and just having small
talk how do you know when to take a turn
how do you know when to shift topics and
how do you even know what topics to
discuss see most of us don't really
think about it because it's almost
second nature and when we get to know
someone we learn more about what makes
them tick and then we learn what topics
we can discuss but when it comes to
teaching AI systems how to interact with
people we have to teach them step by
step what to do and right now it feels
clunky if you've ever tried to talk with
Alexa Siri or Google assistant you can
tell that it or they can still sound
cold and have you ever gotten annoyed
when they didn't understand what you
were saying and you had to rephrase what
you wanted 20 times just to play a song
alright well to the credit of the
designers realistic communication is
really hard and there's a whole branch
of sociology called conversation
analysis that tries to make blueprints
for different types of conversation
types like customer service or
counseling teaching and others
I've been collaborating with a
conversation analysts at the lab to try
to help our AI systems hold more human
sounding conversations this way when you
have an interaction with the Chapa on
your phone or a voice based system in
the car it sounds a little more human
and less cold and disjointed so I
created a piece of art that
to highlight the robotic clunky
interaction to help us understand as
designers why it doesn't sound human yet
and well what we can do about it the
piece is called BOTS a bot and it puts
one conversational system against
another and then exposes it to the
general public and what ends up
happening is that you get something that
tries to mimic human conversation but
fall short sometimes it works and
sometimes it gets into these well loops
of misunderstanding so even though the
machine to machine conversation can make
sense grammatically and colloquially it
can still end up feeling cold and
robotic and despite checking all the
boxes the dialogue lacks soul and those
one-off quirks that make each of us who
we are
so while it might be grammatically
correct and uses all the right hashtags
and emojis can end up sounding
mechanical and well a little creepy and
we call this the uncanny valley you know
that creepiness factor of tech where
it's close to human but just slightly
off and the piece will start being one
way that we can test for the humanists
of a conversation and the parts that get
lost in translation so there are other
things that get lost in translation too
like human intuition right now computers
are gaining more autonomy they can take
care of things for us like change the
temperature of our houses based on our
preferences and even help us drive on
the freeway but there are things that
you and I do in person that are really
difficult to translate to AI so think
about the last time that you saw an old
classmate or co-worker did you give them
a hug or go in for a handshake you
probably didn't think twice because
you've had so many built up experiences
that had you do one or the other and as
an artist I feel that access to one's
intuition your unconscious knowing is
what helps us create amazing things big
ideas from that abstract nonlinear place
in our consciousness that is the
culmination of all of our experiences
and if we want computers to relate to us
and help amplify our creative abilities
I feel that we'll need to start thinking
about how to make computers be intuitive
so I wanted to explore how something
like human intuition could be directly
translated to art
official intelligence and I created a
piece that explores computer-based
intuition in a physical space the piece
is called wayfinding and it's set up as
a symbolic compass that has four kinetic
sculptures each one represents a
direction north east south and west and
their sensors set up on the top of each
sculpture that capture how far away you
are from them and the data that gets
collected ends up changing the way the
sculptures move and the direction of the
compass the thing is the piece doesn't
work like the automatic door sensor that
just opens when you walk in front of it
see your contribution is only a part of
its collection of lived experiences in
all of those experiences affect the way
that it moves so when you walk in front
of it it starts to use all of the data
that it's captured throughout its
exhibition history or its intuition to
mechanically respond to you based on
what is learned from others and what
ends up happening is that as
participants we start to learn the level
of detail that we need in order to
manage expectations from both humans and
machines we can almost see our intuition
being played out on the computer
picturing all of that data being
processed in our minds I my hope is that
this type of art will help us think
differently about intuition and how to
apply that to AI in the future so these
are just a few examples of how I'm using
art to feed into my work as a designer
and researcher of artificial
intelligence and I see it as a crucial
way to move innovation forward because
right now there are a lot of extremes
when it comes to AI popular movies show
it as this destructive force while
commercials are showing it as a savior
to solve some of the world's most
complex problems but regardless of where
you stand it's hard to deny that we're
living in a world that's becoming more
and more digital by the second our lives
revolve around our devices smart
appliances and more and I don't think
this will let up anytime soon so I'm
trying to embed more humanists from the
start and I have a hunch that bringing
art into an AI research process is a way
to do just that
thank you
[Applause]